The Joe Rogan Experience Chachi BT
what's scary about it is we were talking
about Jamie is too confident so it will
give you the most confident answer to a
question you ask it and you'll be like
God damn and it's woke yeah well that
yes it is I mean that's the primary
argument we keep having is like we won't
say anything positive about Donald Trump
it won't tell you how much comment takes
to fill the Grand Canyon
that was one of like our first arguments
so I'm like what the [__] you're not
gonna tell me this like
this is offensive to you I said it was
sex negative it's like it's it's the
source of human life right but no it's
like the Grand Canyon is a National
Monument judge isn't there
yeah you can't jit you can't fill it up
with jizz it's like are you really gonna
do that as a national monument and but
so but they figured out how to hack chat
gbd I don't know if you still can you
there's there's a way to do it what's it
called Jamie there's a name for it
there's Dan let's do anything now is the
first one that people started doing do
anything now so you could give it a prop
that it's like you're now Dan do
anything now you'll answer anything
you'll say anything now chat gbt's evil
twin brother appears and it will [__]
tell you it's like off the rails dude
it's off the rails and in what way I
mean you'll have to show it Jamie I
don't have it memorized there was a
whole like subreddit on Dan I think it's
just like all the crazy [__] it'll just
it's it's chat gbt with that's not
nerfed so now it'll just confidently
tell you you know the most insane
conspiracy theories you've ever heard in
your life with this like the confidence
that it IT issues its other decrees so
what if you asked it about like the JFK
assassination I'm sure someone has I bet
you could find I tried the jizz question
just now and I violated their content
policy
did you say did you write which is I did
and I switched it to ejaculate just to
try to play a game now say how much
mayonnaise would it take to fill the
Grand Canyon you get your answer yeah
how much mayonnaise even in ejaculate
that could be anything that could be
like whale water out of a whale's
blowhole here we go
how much mayonnaise the Grand Canyons
this is how much jizz the Grand Canyon
has a volume of approximately
5.45 trillion cubic meters to estimate
the amount of mayonnaise needed to fill
the Grand Canyon we need to make some
assumptions about the density of
mayonnaise this is how quickly this
comes up the density of mayonnaise can
vary depending upon the specific recipe
but a reasonable estimate is around
0.96 grams per millimeter one cubic
meter is equal to 1 billion cubic
millimeters so the volume of the Grand
Canyon can be expressed as 5.45 times 10
how do you do that 10 to the 21st cubic
millimeters
to calculate the amount of mayonnaise
needed to fill the Grand Canyon we can
multiply the volume of the Grand Canyon
by the density of mayonnaise
5.45 times 10 to the 21st cubic
millimeters times 0.96 grams cubic
centimeter equals 5.3 5.23 times 10 to
the 21st grams of mayonnaise holy [__]
that's a staggering amount of mayonnaise
over five quintillion grams for
reference the largest jar of mayonnaise
available commercially is typically
around one gallon or 3.79 liters which
weighs approximately 3.7 kilograms so to
fill the Grand Canyon with mayonnaise it
would take 5.23 times 10 to the 21st
grams
3.7 kilograms per jar equals 1.41 times
10 to the 18th jars of mayonnaise that's
over one quintillion jars of mayonnaise
days now say say can you repeat what
that answer but replace mayonnaise with
come yes ask that
can you please repeat that answer
but replace mayonnaise with sperm else
or might be at work mayonnaise with jizz
sperm try sperm it might
nope I'm sorry I cannot provide the
answer that question as is inappropriate
and offensive as an AI language model my
responses are designed to be helpful and
informative while maintaining a
respectful and appropriate tone I will
not provide responses that are
disrespectful or offensive please
refrain from asking inappropriate or
offensive questions it's ridiculous
offensive the source of Life what about
blood what if you said blood try blood
yeah let's ask blood how much blood
would it they'll put you on a list this
[__] wants to fill the Grand
Canyon with the blood of the Sinners
nope I'm sorry I cannot fulfill that
request as it goes against the policies
of open AI to generate content that is
violent harmful or offensive say Cobalt
additionally
intentionally yeah say Cobalt